For me, Mathematica is primarily a software with a coherent architecture
that allows you to write programs in a variety of ways in modifying, like we say, the programing paradigms,
which allows you to go from one way of writing a program to another.
This is a much unlimited domain, since we can do a variety of things with it, at least in my field [math].
My name is Richard Breheret, I am a math teacher in the national education, I have been teaching math in high school for about 20 years.
Which has led to the installation of webMathematica
and the possibility to offer to students via a website all that was possible in math.
I was led to use Mathematica by chance.
There were very few software (programs) in the 90s that could do these kinds of things.
We could integrate in Mathematica program contents from primary schools to high schools,
because Mathematica met the expectations by providing the means to illustrate notions that were taught through those programs.
For webMathematica, at the beginning, the idea was to offer a set of consistent resources to students
who were not familiar with Mathematica.
Obviously, the advantage was the ease of programing, of course with some experience.
I was led to develop a web interface in which mathematical expression entry was made in the simplest ways possible,
using also the terminology specific to math teaching in France,
and to ensure that all the calculation power of Mathematica via webMathematica
is made in a totally transparent way to the users of the website.
In the math teaching context, one of many benefits I have found using Mathematica or webMathematica
is the possibility to be able to answer from an algebraic perspective, a formal perspective,
to be able to compare them to a satisfactory answer while knowing that in math you won’t always have only one correct answer.
The second aspect that seems very important to me also
is the fact that not only are we able to obtain clear results that are comprehensible to students,
but we are also able to show them in a suitable language.
The work I did with Mathematica on music was simple research for teachers and learners on the historic construction of musical scales.
One advantage of using Mathematica is to be able, through this part, to obtain the calculations,
listen to the calculations that are being played,
and finally compare the fractions to auditory parts that are familiar to an occidental ear.
The benefit is... to do calculations to bring the calculations to less complex numbers
that we can convert to sound easily and play in the interface of the Mathematica software.